قال مصدر طبي فلسطيني ان 50 شهيدا و 120
مصابا سقطوا في قصف اسرائيلي على المناطق
الغربيه لخان يونس خلال ال 24 ساعه
الماضيه لمتابعه هذا التطور ينضم الينا من
رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام تفاصيل
اوفى عن كيفيه سقوط هؤلاء الشهداء وهذه
ووقوع هذه
الاصابات الجيش الاسرائيلي هو منذ يومين
على الاقل بات يكثف من غاراته واستهدافه
لمدينه خان يونس القصف الاكثر عنفا والقصف
الاكثر كثافه هو على مدينه خانيونس والان
في خضم هذه العمليه الاسرائيليه الجديده
التي تقدمت منها الدبابات الاسرائيليه
وتوغلت في مناطق مختلفه في مدينه خانيونس
باتت تحاصر احياء مهمه ورئيسيه في قلب
مدينه خانيونس الليله الماضيه وصباح هذا
اليوم الجيش الاسرائيلي كثف من غاراته
احزمه ناريه عنيفه شنتها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه في المناطق المق الغربيه
وايضا في المناطق
الجنوبيه لمدينه خانيونس وايضا الاخطر من
كل ذلك انها باتت تستهدف المناطق والمدارس
التي يتواجد فيها نازحون فلسطينيون وهذا
ربما يشير الى ارتفاع اعداد الشهداء فجاه
كان هناك اعداد شهداء قليله الان 50 شهيد
مره واحده لكن الاخطر ايضا من كل ذلك ان
هؤلاء الشهداء ما زال عدد منهم متواجد في
المدارس ما زال عدد منهم متواجد في في الش
ارع جراء استهداف الجيش الاسرائيلي لهؤلاء
النازحين الذين كان بعضهم في المدارس
وبعضهم حاول الخروج من مدينه خانيونس
متوجها الى مدينه رفح عبر طرق التفافه
فالطرق الرئيسيه قطعتها الدبابات
الاسرائيليه وباتت متمركزه على مفترقات
اساسيه تمنع وصول السكان من المناطق
الشرقيه الى المناطق الغربيه ومن ثم الى
مدينه رفح عبر شارع الرشيد لكن هذه الطرق
الرئيسيه باتت مقطوعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
يتواجد على هذه المفترقات اساسيه وبالتالي
الجيش الاسرائيلي بات يستهدف حتى النازحون
الذين يحاولون الدخول من طرق التفافه
وبالتالي هناك اعداد من الشهداء لا تستطيع
سيارات الاسعاف الوصول اليهم ونقلهم الى
المستشفيات حتى الشهداء الذين ينقلون عدد
منهم وصل الى مستشفى ابو يوسف النجار في
مدينه رفح لان ال الشهداء المتواجدين في
تلك المناطق لا تستطيع سيارات الاسعاف
الوصول اليهم والشهداء في المناطق الغربيه
خاصه في المناطق البعيده نوعا ما عن مناطق
تمركز الدبابات الاسرائيليه لا تستطيع
سيارات الاسعاف انتشالهم واجلاهم الى
مستشفى ناصر لان المستشفى بات محاصرا
الدبابات الاسرائيليه تتواجد من الجهه
الجنوبيه لمستشفى ناصر تتواجد من الجهه
الغربيه ايضا الجهه الشرقيه كذلك الدبابات
الاسرائيليه متواجده ايضا الجهه الجنوبيه
غير بعيد
ومتواجده في منطقه الصناعه ومنطقه حي
الامل وبالتالي هذه المناطق ومحيط مستشفى
ناصر بات يتعرض الى القصف الاكثر عنفا حتى
في مدينه خانيونس وبالتالي هناك اعداد من
الشهداء والجرحى وسترتفع خلال الساعات
القادمه اذا استطاعت سيارات الاسعاف
الوصول الى الشهداء الذين ما زالوا
متواجدين في المدارس وفي المناطق الغربيه
لكن ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي رغم انه يقصف
محيط مستشفى ناصر الا انه ايضا ما زال
يقصف المناطق الغربيه لمدينه خان يونس
وبالاخص منطقه المواصي وعندما نتحدث عن
منطقه المواصي نحن نتحدث عن المنطقه التي
منذ اليوم الاول ل الحرب الاسرائيليه على
غزه والجيش الاسرائيلي يميزها يميزها في
الخارطه التي كان ينشرها المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان ينشر خارطه ويميز
هذه المنطقه على اساس انها منطقه انسانيه
منطقه امنه وبالتالي يتواجد فيها النازحون
الفلسطينيون ولجوا اليها نصبوا هناك خياما
الان الجيش الاسرائيلي يستهدف هذه الخيام
يستهدف المناطق التي يتواجد فيها النازحون
الفلسطينيون بل وتقدمت الدبابات وباتت
مقتربه بشكل كبير في تلك المنطقه وبالتالي
بات تهديد كبير على النازحين الفلسطينيين
الذين يتواجدون في منطقه المواصي ايضا
منطقه المواصي يتواجد فيها عدد من مقرات
المؤسسات الدوليه والمؤسسات في قطاع غزه
خاصه انهم نزحوا ايضا ونقلوا مقراتهم من
مدينه غزه باتجاه تلك المنطقه منذ اليوم
الاول لبدء الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه
الاعلانات وطلب من المؤسسات الدوليه
التوجه الى تلك المنطقه الجيش الاسرائيلي
يكثف من غاراته في تلك المنطقه يستهدف
الخيام التابعه للنازحين الفلسطينيين
الذين نصبوا هناك خياما وغرقت الليله بسبب
الامطار وكانت هناك احوال جويه سيئه ورغم
كل ذلك الجيش الاسرائيلي كان يستهدفهم
وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي بات مركزا على
خانيونس الجيش الاسرائيلي يركز من عملياته
على هذه المدينه ويعزل الاخطر انه يعزل
مجمع ناصر مجمع ناصر هو المجمع الاهم الان
في هذا الوقت لس سياما وان مجمع الشفاء
الطبي خرج عن الخدمه اغلب مستشفيات مدينه
غزه خرجت عن الخدمه وعندما خروجها عن
الخدمه كان هناك بعض التحويلات وبعض
المرضى نقلوا الى المستشفيات في وسط وجنوب
القطاع الجل الاعظم من هؤلاء نقلوا الى
مستشفى ومجمع ناصر لانه الذي يحتوي على
العدد الاكبر من الاسره الذي يحتوي على
العدد الاكبر من التخصصات من الاطباء من
غرف العنايه المكثفه ومن كل شيء من
المستلزمات ومن الادويه
وبالتالي المستشفيات الان في خطر حقيقي
لان خروج هذا المستشفى عن الخدمه يهدد
حياه العشرات بل الالاف من المرضى لان
المستشفيات المتبقيه في الوسط وجنوب قطاع
غزه هي مستشفيات صغيره تشي بان تجربه
مستشفى الشفاء التي شهدناها في شمال
القطاع من الممكن ان تتكرر
الان كل المؤشرات الان تشير الى ان ما حدث
في مجمع الشفاء الطبي يحدث الان في مجمع
ممع ناصر من محاصره الجيش الاسرائيلي لهذا
المجمع من جميع الجهات وايضا القصف
الاسرائيلي الذي يستهدف محيطه مدارس تابعه
لوكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين الانرو هيي من
تحيط بهذا المستشفى ورغم كل ذلك استهدفهم
الجيش الاسرائيلي التخوف الاكبر من اقتحام
هذا المستشفى ورغم محاصره هذا المستشفى
الا انه ما زال يعمل ما زال يقدم الخدمه
لمئات بل الالاف من المرضى ومن الجرحى
المتواجدين في هذا المستشفى والذين لا
يستطيع الاطباء اجلائهم لانه لا يوجد متسع
لديهم لا يوجد متسع في مستشفيات قطاع غزه
المختلفه في مستشفيات الجنوب على وجه
الخصوص في مستشفيات الوسط ايضا الا ايضا
هذه المستشفيات هي مستشفيات صغيره مستشفى
ابو يوسف النجار هو مستشفى صغير لا يستطيع
استيعاب الجرحى الذين يصلون اليه فما بالك
بنقل جرحى ايضا من خانيونس فما بالك بنقل
جرحى يحتاجون الى ادويه يحتاجون الى
مستلزمات يحتاجون الى غرف عنايه مكثفه
ومستشفى وسط قط قطاع غزه مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى لا يمكن الوصول اليه او بات الوصول
اليه خطر جدا في ظل تقدم الدبابات
الاسرائيليه باتجاه شارع الرشيد ووصولها
الى مناطق قريبه من هذا الشارع الاساسي
والرئيسي وهو الشارع الاساسي المتبقي الذي
يصل الوسط بالجنوب الان مناطق وسط قطاع
غزه باتت محاصره لان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يحاصرها من الجهه الشماليه ويمنع وصول
السكان الى مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع والان
يمنعهم من الوصول الى جنوب القطاع الى
خانيونس ورا صح وبالتالي منطقه الوسط باتت
محاصره وبالتاكيد له اثار كارثيه على
السكان يمنع وصول الغذاء اليهم يمنع وصول
المساعدات يمنع وصول الادويه يمنع وصول
المستلزمات الطبيه والاهم يمنع وصول
الوقود القادم اليهم من مناطق من مناطق
الجنوب الى مناطق الوسط من اجل تشغيل
المستشفى
والمستشفى في دير البلح هو مستشفى وحيد لا
يوجد مستشفيات في وسط قطاع غزه بخلاف هذا
المستشفى مستشفى الشهداء الاقصى ومستشفى
العوده المخص خصص للولاده وبالتالي عدم
وصول الوقود الى هذه المستشفيات ايضا يهدد
حياه المئات بل الالاف من السكان ويهدد
حياه المرضى في هناك ويهدد حياه بكل تاكيد
العشرات من النازحين في تلك المناطق
وبالتالي الخطر الان هو على مستشفى ناصر
والعيون تتجه الى مستشفى ناصر في ظل
استمرار محص محاصرته من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي واطلاق النار واطلاق الغذائ
باتجاه المناطق المحيطه الى هذا المستشفى
وحتى ان بعض الطلقات وصل الى قلب هذا
المستشفى بالاضافه الى ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي استهدفه عده مرات وهدده عده
مرات خلال هذه الحرب شكرا لك من رفح مراسل
الجزيره هشام زقوط